This one here is the correct answer. Let's see why. The first two can't be
right, because we're multiplying with a decimal number here. And then when we
divide, we're not going to get an integer. We're going to get some fractional
number, 0.0 and a little bit, 0.9 maybe at this end, and so on. But that's not
what we want. We wanted to reduce these, this range of integers to that range
of integers. So it's gotta be one of these two, and now the question is do we
divide by 256 or do we divide by 255? And it doesn't seem like it would matter
much, but it really does, namely if value happens to be the very last element,
if it happens to be 255. Then this equation wouldn't work, 255 times 6, again,
divided by 255 would be 6, and we're only supposed to get values between 0 and
5. All right, here we have the formula, and now it's time to put it to work in
Java.